hey guys and welcome to a brand new
video today I'm going to be doing
something that's been requested quite a
few times and that is to flip from one
GP uh so going all the way from 1 GP to
1 mil using the ground exchange only uh
this going to be really challenging
because the first item you have to buy
has to be for 1 GP and not a lot of
items are going to sell for that uh so
the first item is going to be very
important cuz you can easily get screwed
if it doesn't sell back and uh yeah so
we're going to go all the way to 1 mil
we're going to do this all in today's
episode and so over this is over the
course a couple days of course but we're
going to leave room to do this in the
future all right hope you guys enjoy and
let's get started so the first item I'm
thinking of doing I've done a lot of
research and we're going to be using GE
tracker to have a look at the uh day
graph and what we're looking for is an
item that will drop down to 1 GP
occasionally like this item gian's
cookbook it's a really random item from
The Gnome cooking mini game uh not
really used for much else but I'm some
Sor so bought that for 33k but even if
we could sell it for 100 coins or 200
coins that would still be amazing so
much easier to start once you have even
a couple hundred coins uh so we're going
to go ahead and buy one of these and
just hope that the person that sells us
to me does not realize that you can buy
it right from The Gnome shop all right
be back in a while all right we're back
and clearly someone didn't realize that
you can buy the book right from The
Gnome anyway we sold it for 99 GP that
is pretty awesome uh next up I think we
want to try some of these boots uh we
can see the BL blue boots here um drop
down don't have enough to 100 and and
from 781 we're going to try that next uh
teal boots maybe put an offer we'll just
put an offering for a couple random
different boots uh cuz they're kind of a
fashion Escape item nobody actually
really buy and sells these very much uh
try teal
boots and I'll try pfron for blue boots
don't think we're going to get it we
need a little bit more money for these
ones since a a bit more common do
25 and uh we'll continue to do the
gian's cookbook as well
we'll bump it up maybe
to 5
GP and we'll
try 10 oh [__] do four GP and 10 all
right we'll come back hopefully with
some more sales okay so unfortunately
the boots didn't work but we did sell
another four gan's cookbooks for about
well 99 each and we got four of them so
we're going to pull out the rest of
these offers and uh well 420 and uh
we're going to try to put the offers in
for the blue boots a bit High
blue boots and we're going to pop them
in
for
105 try four of those and uh we'll
continue doing the gon's cookbooks since
they are working pretty well and we'll
go buy another J's D the hell is that
and do another 5 GP each and another 10
of those now hopefully we can get the
blue boots cuz they were selling for
about 700 each let's have a look on G
tracker same they going for about 700
and then they drop to about 102
occasionally so we're definitely
hopefully will buy those definitely
hopefully and uh yeah hopefully we'll
get some sales all right these blue
boots are working exceptionally well
this is so much quicker um these only
took like a couple hours to buy and sell
where the other ones were almost like a
day in total anyway we sold them for 780
each we're going to cash check up to
3129 so we're absolutely going to go
ahead and buy more of those
105 and I will'll put
in 20
sorry 20
quantity uh we'll go
15 and uh we're going to split this up
with another item the green
boot uh cuz if you have a quick look on
GE tracker similar thing they trade a
bit less per day but um they drop down
to 100 pretty regularly as you can see
same with the blue boots and uh they
trade probably half as much but still
could be a good margin put them in again
for 105 and we'll do 15 of these as well
uh 14 I
guess and uh John's cookbooks are going
to be updated pretty quickly here
they're not coming through very quick
but yeah hopefully these boots will work
out well all the boots have sold which
is really exciting these things are
actually really quick uh they take a
while to buy but they sell really
quickly so we sold all the blue boots
for 780 each netting us like
um 10K
and the green boots we sold for 870 each
then it has like 11k or something and uh
we actually sold the cookbook for 500
coins each which is cool uh and we're
almost at about 25k coins which is
awesome um so we're going to go buy some
more of those books or um sorry books
more of the um boots but first of all
we're going to buy a new item and I
think that's going to be this one here
the black plate legs trimmed as you can
see it looks like has a 29k margin and
um if we go down to the day graph looks
like recently bought for about 18K
selling for
48k that's extremely good we'll put an
offering for 19k for the black plate
legs oh my God
19010 that's good and buy one of those
and we'll go ahead and buy some more of
the boots as well cuz they're just
working so well and uh we'll do another
15 of each I
believe and yeah so hopefully we can
actually flip this black plate legs for
a 30k profit that'd be awesome and we be
back in a couple hours I'm really
excited for this item 46k we sold it for
that was extremely quick look we haven't
even sold the other boots yet 46k in
profit that is awesome we're going to
definitely go ahead and buy well let's
see uh two more for now so 38k in total
be investing in there and we'll sell off
these boots un unfortunately if we'd
actually sold them we may have had
enough and what'll be selling this for
[Music]
780 and the other ones
four uh 870 just a little bit more
nice and uh is there anything we want to
do with the rest of our money so this is
kind of just a throwback to an item I
used to do back in the day and this
would have been a great oh my God look
at this down to 2
GP maybe we can snag some for cheap here
we're going to put an offer in
for three well do 2K each ad PL legs now
this is like my very first series I used
to do this item a lot in uh we'll do it
for
20501 and we'll go for four of them all
right guys hopefully my original item
will still work quite well nicely and I
will come back hopefully with everything
sold all right good news everybody the
black plate legs have sold for 46k again
netting us a massive profit 92k from uh
30 8K is about a 55k profit that is
extremely good uh blue boots again came
through for about a 10K profit these are
still selling off and the admin plate
legs we did manage to actually buy all
four of them and we're getting about a
7500 profit on each one getting us about
23k or something like that so we have
134k in our inventory which is nice um I
think we're just going to put an offer
in for those blue boots quite a few of
them because they are still extremely
good for their price and they do
actually buy really quickly
uh so we're going to go put in a
100 um we'll leave this in maybe even
200 almost uh because they trade like
600 a day and we are consistently buying
these for 105 and I think that is still
a reasonable price to put in for um
maybe that may take a day or two to buy
but that's still good um and next up we
want to try some of these items on this
highest margin page on G tracker so we
popped in 100K and these are the items
that have come up not going to do the
super store clearly not going to be good
but what about the black elegant
skirt 30k margin on that uh we're
definitely going to put another offer in
for the we'll just do that now um for
the black playl T another one for 46k or
not 46k sorry I put them in for
19010 uh but they do take a while so two
is probably reasonable all right so the
black elegant shirt looks like it's
going from 45k to 77k pretty frequently
trades how many a day
85 uh that's not too bad we could buy a
couple in an hour
easily and we'll put an offering for
46k just a clue scroll reward kind of
similar to the other random pieces of
clothing we've been doing let's do 49k
and we'll do one of those oh you
instantly bought
it okay well we bought it for 4650
interesting well I guess we'll try to
sell it for7 77k that's not a big deal
honestly I was prepared to buy that
anyway
77k and um yeah I think we'll just leave
that for now and hopefully we'll sell
that off okay so the black elegant shirt
did end up selling back for 77k um not
too long later honestly uh so that is
a uh 30k profit on that which is nice uh
the black deide trimmed legs are still
working extremely well uh green boots
have sold and the adant legs have sold
as well
uh so we're up to about 200k and now
usually what I do I just kind of have G
Tracker open as soon as I get up to 200k
um okay we'll go filter the item up to
200k now uh flipping and pay to play is
extremely easy guys I've been doing free
toplay videos for so long now that this
just seems uh so easy now so green men's
Alm uh something that I am interested in
doing another video on uh still haven't
gotten the requirements to do this yet
but we will I'll leave it kind of vag
like that anyway uh 100 110 into
140k uh per day traded
um I mean maybe we could try maybe we'll
try sniping one for 55k not sure if
we're going to get that or not um we'll
try
green men's ale
matured try for 60k do one of those I'm
not sure if that's going to work or not
we'll maybe leave that one and highest
margin black elegant shirt could do that
again Cannon Baye going to lose too much
of our money there uh piscus hid Hood uh
that looks good 27k profit and uh let's
see how many I trade it a
day and not that
many let's look at the day graph here 67
into 995 we'll try
it
piscus that's how you say it
and we're oh my God it's not an accurate
price we're looking to buy it
for
68k looks
good um but I think we should probably
stick with the other two items we've
been doing uh the we'll put another
offering for the black plate legs
trimmed probably going to go ahead and
maybe just max out as much as we can
here four of
those sounds good and uh yeah I'm really
happy with how this is going interesting
to see how the Greenman AO works and
we'll be back in a
while oh wow we just bought it okay I
was literally going to end the clip but
I guess we'll pop it in sell 60k we
bought it for oh my god
um where was it again greenman's ale
matured yeah it looks like it's
regularly going for
175 all right let's try popping in for
140 137k how about okay now we're going
to go that was exciting okay we're back
and not everything has sold yet but most
importantly the greenman's ale has sold
for 137k that is exciting uh that is a
well 70k Profit just on that one item
we'll definitely go buy another two of
those now the blue boots have kind of
stopped coming through we have about 100
of them I think we're going to sell
those off and uh well we're going to
sell them for what was it now now I
can't even remember 9 or
780 yeah 780 and that's going to n us a
pretty big profit honestly on the boots
84k and we bought them all for 11k that
is a 70k profit 75k actually and um we
also have the piscal arious hood coming
through uh we're going to sell that
for is that 30k profit or something I
think we're going to pop it in for
94k not a huge profit but still good and
the black plate legs have come through
two of them at least and we're going to
pop those in for 46k all right so
hopefully we can buy some more of those
ALS and we'll be back okay it really
isn't been long at all it's only been a
couple minutes honestly uh 1020 and uh
we have flipped another greenman's ale
now it's not as good as it looks but
still extremely good 174k and we did
bump up the Buy price to about
101k and that's still at 75k profit on
that that is extremely good piscal
arious Hood we sold for
94k uh
Ness 30 a less 34 or something and uh 24
sorry and that will leave us with
367k blue boots are selling off but kind
of a bit slower mind you it's only been
like 20 minutes and these have yet to
sell but when we do we'll get another
92k there bring this pretty close to
500k uh in pure cash which is awesome
we're going to go ahead and buy another
green menale for 101k for sure and are
going to go peruse the list once again
so once again now that we have a higher
cash Shack I'm just going to come here
filter out um up to 300K I guess 300K
and see what G tracker is going to give
me here so halfon
spectacles huh 110k we let's have a look
at that and T's plate
body
interesting um Half Moon
spectacles how many trade a day 30
that's not actually too bad for how big
a margin this is looking like and if we
go down to the day graph
here 78k into 189 that is extremely
interesting think we're going to put an
offer in for that so 81k for the half
moon
spectacles Half Moon spectacles I guess
this is a clue reward I've never heard
of it before I go for 91k and just do
one of those all right and last up uh
we're going just come a look at this
random item I've never heard of it
before the dark infin Infinity Color Kit
trades quite a bit couple hundred a day
and looks like a 7K margin it's not as
good but for how much it trades I think
that's still worth doing again never
really heard of this dark Infinity Color
Kit I do it for
29k and we'll just max out as much as we
can afford which is going to be six all
right hopefully we can actually flip
these spectacles another quick check in
uh we have sold another greenman's ale
for another like 75k profit that has
amazing going to go buy another one of
those look 74k in profit right off that
definitely going to go buy oh [__] we
can only afford one uh oh
wait luckily we did sell another black
play legs we can afford to that's good
uh so 101 we're going to buy two of
those hopefully we can get a couple more
of those cuz you're getting pretty close
to the one mil Mark uh which is pretty
much my goal um and I guess we'll sell
these back
29k and what we looking to sell those
for again like
try
39K so still a decent margin on that 117
and we bought them for 87 30k on that
not bad at all and yeah we'll be back in
a
bit all right so we finally bought a
pair of the half moon spectacles for
91k that's exciting uh we were planning
on selling them for an extremely good
margin it was
like yeah 189 I think that's what it was
let's go recheck here do we still have
it open
yes 189 that's extremely good uh for
items like this G tracker actually is
pretty accurate because uh the trade
limit for this item
is not extremely high so this uh pricing
here is actually probably right on the
dot uh so
189 uh going to net us a 100K
margin extremely nice uh greenman's ale
we have another one selling for
173 and the black plate legs have also
off and uh we did sell an Infinity kit
uh but after we sell that 173k plus 188k
uh we're going to get pretty damn close
we could probably finish this up in a
couple more flips and um well we got we
got 339k what are we doing we got to
find something okay the cannon base has
a very interesting price right now um I
guess we'll go and try buying a couple
of these I don't know if we'd actually
sell it for
230 um but I mean still could probably
get a 20 30k margin on that
and it should be a quick item Cannon
base buy him for
186 and we'll go
for one I guess and it's not the best
item but I guess we'll just leave that
for now okay so we have sold off most of
our stuff halfon spectacles coming in
for a massive flip 188k from uh what was
it bought them for 91k so that is a well
almost a 100K profit Cannon base we did
actually sell for 223 interesting enough
we got like a 30k profit there the other
greenman's ale has come through and the
dark Infinity color kits I guess just
completed um so 84k and these blue boots
are coming through so slowly um so
that's just going to leave us with a
little bit more money to earn and now
we're going to try one last item that
will hopefully get us enough and that is
the briefcase looks like it has a 109k
margin on it um which is pretty awesome
and it's just a cool item anyway L swag
with it so we'll try buying it for
438 brief able my God my spelling brief
case actually we might even be able to
afford two almost not quite though
438 damn it wish those boots would sell
quicker all right we'll find a secondary
item I guess since we can't quite afford
two of these uh light bow tie nice to
try something a little less weird
new Crystal Shield zamra
dehy that looks promising 40K on a item
that trades that much is pretty
good let's have a look at the day graph
quickly and sure 320 we'll try selling
that yeah
samur dhide for
320 and yeah I hope this should be the
last flip and we'll be at our 1 mil all
right so we ended up ditching out on the
briefcase because it was just not
working we didn't end up buying any of
them but the Zam dehy bodies uh bought
so quickly that we managed to do uh two
full flips already we bought two of them
for 330 sold them for 360 each and then
a 60k and another 60k and our final dehy
bodies are in that is going to pop us up
to 1 43k that's over a mil so we're
pretty much done our Challenge and um
yeah so the best items by far were these
Greenman Zale as well as the happon
spectacle really good uh as you can see
I use mostly slow clue scroll type items
not that all of them are from clue
Scrolls but um most of them were and
yeah so it ended up working out pretty
well for me this probably took three or
4 days uh to do entirely uh so it was a
lot slower but still got from 0 to 1 mil
in under a week and um from here it only
take an extra couple days probably to
get to a bond so not that long so I hope
you guys enjoyed the video and if you
want to see more like this please leave
it a like or a comment a suggestion for
something I could do next time or
anything I could improve and yeah I will
see you guys in the next video
[Music]